[Music]
that he is back in action
[Music]
it's been a weird year i really want to
do it the right way man
i'm not going to look at porn nothing i
just want to commit no porn disguise
there's no point no way impossible
rami do you want to stay alone forever
[Music]
you don't even have a real job you do
nothing at a startup that does nothing
they are starting up
[Music]
i just want to figure out my calling for
the romney
to what brings you here i want to change
and
i heard you can help me
speak the straightforward word brother i
know i can be better
i look at my parents and how strong they
are
maybe we should start recycling i think
we should
i want to know who i am i want to
explore they don't want a man like me
anymore they want a man like you he's a
little bit like a woman but he's still
officially a man
look at everything as a blessing my
curse ronnie
truth is everything is both
i'm just trying to do the right thing
whoa you just took the whole thing
what's the wrong way i'm gonna have an
experience
100 milligrams are you happy you think
it took too much
every muslim believes in jesus we
actually think jesus is going to come
back
i'm definitely down for jesus come back
it would mean it was the end of the
world but
[Music]
oh